hmm
[Music]
I was expecting you to finish it
your screen resolution is slightly
different from mine
mine is a little bit more Square that's
absolutely gonna you're a new people
your link is more fat than my link and I
can already see people being super
triggered about this in the comments and
your color your colors are slightly
different
hello hello everyone hello
uh we were getting a little bit tired of
the Ocarina of Time randomizer for a
little bit so yeah I think I've it's uh
in uh Hyrule Field for long enough yeah
for a lifetime we thought it's going to
be a change we're never gonna finish the
the original randomizer anyway because
yeah the uh key sanity was probably a
mistake we just had we're just too busy
to keep a schedule anyway and very soon
there's going to be a lot of Zelda news
anyway and that means I have to work a
lot and then we probably won't stream as
much nah although we might stream the E3
uh E3 oh my God there is no E3 in this
area did you see that yeah I mean the
direct
oh that's cool to hear a balloon
I'll see you later The Blacklist do your
thing
uh yeah let's get started yeah let's get
started do we need to explain to people
what this is well let's go get the sword
first yeah yeah it's all random cave
entrances are all random
I have no way to defend myself yeah uh
this game is this is this is a hard game
guys
you're probably gonna see a few more
game overs than in Ocarina of Time
[Music]
well let's see what we have here take
any road you want that's a good start I
think I'm just gonna get the sword first
because we did I was doing that we did
not randomize the sword cave that's the
only one we kept yeah just a little bit
of getting this hard enough as it is
actually do something actually attack
stuff are you using the d-pad or are you
using that
um
Good Luck we're all counting on you
I might switch it to the to the
controller if I uh I can't hear you guys
like you cannot hear us over the oh the
the the the music is too loud I guess
is that the music of the game too loud
I did crank up the volume of the game
quite a bit
uh
I can turn it down turn it way down
it's still set to my audio levels of the
Ocarina of Time random randomizer thingy
I think that that should should be it
well that's a good start
geez I'm gonna absolutely pummeled
you're getting getting destroyed already
yeah I was kind of looking at your
screen I wasn't really paying attention
to what I was doing I do have to say
well I'm already dead guys that's uh
that's a good sign for uh playing this
game with a Xbox controller is not the
best option to be honest
yeah now that I think about it oh we
should have connected the NES
controllers or SNES controllers I I have
uh we could do that no it's too late
yeah I have to mess around with uh with
game bindings and oh come on just
yeah the d-pad wasn't ah the d-bed
wasn't a good choice on second thought
huh
because it's very uh you have to be very
specific yeah it's not really very uh
the movement is a little bit just grab
it link you
yes
I cannot hear the music now
okay let me see
turn it up a little bit I guess
was here
why something well yeah
this is probably the worst where you
just keep hearing that let's let's put
ocean sound in it it's just oh yeah I
remember that
and every time you you swing the sword
the sound uh resets does it yeah so it's
like
I mean it's 1986.
yeah I think they did a good job for
what they had at the time
well you would imagine because it it
launched a whole franchise
uh so are we gonna explain like the
settings of the the randomizer or
anything or I'm gonna let people figure
it out yeah we'll just let people I
don't even remember half of what we
chose it was mostly because I figured
that a lot of people probably have never
played this game switch controllers work
with Bluetooth on PC so yeah I did have
my Pro Controller synced but it didn't
work in the beginning I was like you
know what screw it
I am because we started this randomizer
way too late
I'm all right I'm about to die too now
by the way
I'm not even gonna bother
I'm not even gonna bother ah
that's probably the way to die
in this game you run into an enemy while
you're slashing at them
so for people who've never played this
game that guy over there
yeah you don't want to mess with him we
are playing the same seed as always just
what like with the previous one so we
both have the same seed
we're just working together so when one
of us finds us the other one will be
able to find it too yup in the same spot
so the first objective is just to find
cave entrances
like normal cave entrances I'm gonna
check what's inside level one oh of
course
okay
uh I found the blue ring that that's
already a like we should just grind for
rupees now yeah I'm just gonna play a
money making game and gamble my life
away oh no well there goes so that's a
good lesson to teach kids just gamble
your life away and ah you'll be good oh
my God this game
well to be fair with these controls it's
this is gonna get some uh
it's gonna take some getting used to
yeah definitely
I mean the game does get easier like
yeah it's just like breath of the wild
the the first few hours are the hardest
and then it just gets easier and easier
because enemies are really hard to avoid
and their hitbox they're well they're
yeah their hitbox is actually bigger
than you think it than you think it is
really yeah I never checked uh the the
data
oh
and with these controls it's pretty
difficult to squeeze yourself like in
between these trees and everything
you are at my Mercy
but as you get more hard stuff the skin
oh it's a secret how much
36. that's not too shabby I'm just gonna
grind for rupees and just buy the blue
ring right away makes the game a lot
easier so much money though
250 yeah it's 250 Tower
oh
some bombs would be nice what happened
to Ocarina of Time Ocarina of Time died
in its sleep
now we we wanted to change
it up a little bit because we've been
playing for like eight episodes and we
were not even close
to getting to the end yeah I think we
made a mistake with the key sanity uh
thing we might have yeah
like normally if we did this every week
it would have been manageable but
oh stop throwing stuff at me
that's a normal playthrough though I'm
not counting the randomizer
uh
this hot this game is a lot harder to
talk and to concentrate at the same time
Ocarina of Time is a breeze
yeah in terms of difficulty this game is
not very forgiving
no
I'm just gonna more bombs
I'm gonna take the C route you always
get a lot of money there
are the enemies are not that difficult
you don't know my name
no you don't know who Jesse is or Dawn
is blasphemy
oh oh no oh no no no no I don't want to
be here
like in my videos I always say at the
end this is Dawn signing off have a good
one better
so I thought most people knew but
obviously not everyone
watches all the way to the to the very
very end as soon as the credits roll
most people are probably uh they're out
give me life do I have bombs I do have
bombs
whoo I have bombs too
but I don't have life uh the sound of
the sea is so annoying pay me for the
door no
all my hard work gone to waste
I hate that guy
he just
takes your money you don't even have a
choice to fight back it's got isn't it
weird how the old men in this game screw
you over more than the the bubbling yeah
and the moblins too they give you money
it's a secret to everyone oh yeah
pay me for my door
how about you pay me to save the world
you live in
are the doors randomized yes uh all cave
entrances all dungeon rooms the only
thing we didn't really mess around with
are the monsters except the bosses we
did randomize the bosses
but the monsters we mostly left as as
they are because this game is already
difficult enough you can buy a hardcore
we're not playing this too oh my God
another one
I'm losing money fast you can buy Hearts
now for three rupees I didn't even bomb
his his uh door
so he didn't even have a door to repair
no he's just oh my God he's just taking
my money is over
he's just taking my money like taking
our money
oh my god well
this way you need to re rewind featuring
but that's cheating
we finished quite a few of these
randomizers of Zelda one by this point
at least like four times right uh maybe
more probably more I think we finished
this one more than linked to the Past
well we played the original
like you you never grew up with the
original no uh and then obviously
neither did I I didn't play it until
after Majora's Mask we played this well
for the first time together actually
yeah back when uh well I did play it
before but it was too hard for me back
then and I was like nope
yeah we uh played the first one uh and
we actually had a good pretty good time
the first time playing this game yeah
well until we get to that until we got
to level six then everything
yeah
then everything uh oh no
oh
my luck
I'm making another 36. why can't you
guys just like hold still for like two
seconds
uh let's see
what
what did I even get hit by
I get hit by hit by something
off screen why cannot wait why can we
not have friendly Merchants like in
Resident Evil 4.
what are you buying
oh no you've never played any Resident
Evil right I played uh seven but that's
the only one
seven yeah I played Seven you you played
Resident Evil seven yeah I played Seven
really why did why do you do why didn't
you play eight it's uh very similar you
just never got around to it
I heard people were it's the same
protagonist too yeah
I heard it wasn't as as good as seven
though what most people it's it's
different
it wasn't as like scary I think should I
buy the shield no I I actually I don't
want to buy the shield I just I want the
blue ring
I just want Mercy
honestly the only thing I really know
about eight is uh
no
I'm just getting all these guys in a row
and you still have more money than I do
oh you didn't take any money
I think oh you did not much though
I keep having to buy Hearts because I
keep dying
seven uh yeah Resident Evil 7 is not
actually the best Resident Evil to start
with because it's so so different
I believe it but it is the one I started
with
well I mean it's it's fine because it is
the better Resident Evil in a long time
anything after four just I don't know I
I think it's pretty pretty bad
foreign
especially story wise and it's not scary
at all
yeah it's more action oriented right
yeah
you're just suplexing guys sure zombie
like guys into the floor I'm sure it has
its audience
oh it did
but
it's not really a horror game anymore at
that point
I guess
this one
oh that wait there was one there oh I
was about to say if this is another door
because I'm gonna plant embalm in his in
his face I'm pretty sure I bombed that
spot and nothing happened
really these guys just keep
I heard Resident Evil 5 is pretty okay
yeah
who's here again
nope in there
oh I found level one oh wow oh really
yeah that's the point I don't know where
it is yeah tell me it's I hope it's
nearby it's here it's probably not
nearby at first uh oh really no but it's
it's very easy to get to look it's right
I was there before here I didn't like
bother to go oh it's underneath the yeah
it's under under the statue okay I
should probably go there uh oh wrong
statue
oh a cave I'll check that cave too
so Jess are you ready to get some uh
tears of the Kingdom news soon is there
gonna be
the every pretty much every February
that they always have a direct
no I've I haven't really kept track of
when the wrecks are but I believe you
won it all right I'll play oh no
he's swearing these guys yeah
I got 50 bucks
oh yeah it's definitely competent as an
action game but it's like if you if you
came off of Resident Evil like starting
with I started with one two three
and never played Code Veronica or any of
the other the other
I played zero
zero is pretty good I thought
oh my good YouTubers and I'm dead
well
yeah it's right I didn't just jump into
you it's right up there
let me just I'm almost we don't have a
candle yet so we cannot burn any okay
there we go
we don't have anything like this is the
part of the game where the entire world
just
destroys you yeah I'm also very excited
for uh tears of the Kingdom news
we need to see some gameplay already
come on
look at I think most people are
interested in the game because they like
breath well they're gonna be sold on
this story anyway
you know it look it looks cool it looks
dark
the Ganondorf is back and he looks
terrifying so I think most people are on
board but we need to see gameplay we
need to see why this game is different
what's gonna set this game apart from
breath of the Wild
yeah definitely it was here that's what
we need to know we need to know Nintendo
because I've seen some people uh
maybe you uh you have a your own opinion
about that uh
I've seen some complaints that they are
handling the marketing for tears of the
Kingdom very badly
I personally don't really I don't really
agree I mean
I I think it could be better there it's
not great but it's
it's definitely nowhere near I'm inside
the dungeon Island I will wait for you
it's definitely not as good as breath of
the wild though no but Barack the world
was a brand new direction for the series
and it needed to sell the switch Yeah it
had the advantage of being a launch
title yeah and with tears of the Kingdom
itself and like
yeah I personally kind of enjoy the
secrecy a little bit I mean it does kind
of uh I just want an essence of the old
days when we didn't really have
like easy ways to access information
like this or at the very least
not as many it's not this one not as
many people really
like had internet or anything or they
use the internet
oh I I did not know anything about
Majora's Mask when it came out
I don't know nowadays it's very
difficult to escape from information
like this
even if you um
like you're gonna get like Curious
anyway like to look
at the information that's a money making
game up there is that yeah is it
underneath the thing
since inside spectacle Rock
really uh sorry under the under this
statue right there yeah
not spectacle Rock what am I saying
spectacle Rock okay well your color
scheme is very different than mine is it
oh wait why is the door open on yours
uh uh that's weird
is it like
is that a I don't know
okay it's skeletons uh it's boomerang
guy for me
red ones
the easiest dungeon enemy
I think these are the level two guys
they're not supposed to be here
I mean did we randomize the dungeon
monsters I think we did well I think I
was I was probably gonna be stuck here
if I didn't have bombs
I have bumps so I'll probably be fine
I'm ready it's so weird why is this door
closed
I did you like I didn't do anything I've
never been in here
I cannot even see if it's a locked or or
a closed door
so uh yeah
oh
okay more skeletons
so did we do mixed quests we did for the
dungeons so that means you can also you
can walk walk through walls yeah I was
gonna say you remember that
wait are we suck
I don't have a key for the
reason why I don't
did I miss uh like a walkthrough door
somewhere
uh please don't tell me we need to
stabiliter to get like
up here
have you ever heard about the Lego great
Deku Tree set leak
was that a leak or wasn't it just an
announcement
I thought it was just uh
announcement but if it's a leak then uh
there is it still uh like up for a view
or
what the heck is going on why is this
door closed
did you just have a key no I didn't
I think you can at least you can buy
keys in the Overworld in this game
I cannot see if it's a key though or I'm
wasting all of my bombs because I don't
know where to go now it's open what the
heck
uh can you bomb some spots I only have
one bomb left
not these two uh not the walls here I
bumped both of these
all of them while the two of them yeah I
bombed both of them but they can also
try walking through them yeah okay you
like I bombed these two
and the left one I don't remember if I
bombed it maybe you should try I only
have one bomb left I don't want to waste
it
it's a leak from a survey okay
does that mean we're gonna get Ocarina
of Time and
like HD or
what what
is going on with this dungeon
Ocarina of Time HD remake
I think we are not able to do anything
here I think we need do we need to step
ladder in like
the room to the right maybe to go like
up or down well we bumped all of the
walls in here did we
and I'm stuck in the wall oh no I'm not
so weird
ah crap I didn't mean to do that they're
gonna give us uh of course two hearts I
couldn't have time HD and super high def
60 FPS and I'm dead
blue Lino of course
uh I wonder if you're gonna need to find
keys in another dungeon King keys are
not dungeon exclusive like in other
Zelda games yeah true we didn't get
blocked by Keys though
now we just cannot go anywhere yeah
luckily you keep your money in this game
when you die
what's in here
there's nothing there there's nothing
I'm playing so impatient keep getting
hit because I'm impatient I'm just
running into enemies
enemies keep running into me
they tend to do that yeah
sometimes when they're like appearing on
the edge of the screen just when you're
about to like
leave the area and then they just oh my
God really
you can just buy keys
we're gonna have to keep this stream uh
short This Time by the way because we
were messing around too much with the
randomizer and we also watched the movie
before beforehand yeah
because normally uh if it was up to me
we could go on for many more hours but
Jesse has to catch a train back home
yeah
oh it's another Secret
oh only four you cheap bastard
they imagine being like that someone
gets in the street just give randomly
gives you four dollars and you're like
you cheap bastard
no I don't wanna want any of your stuff
I could use a Magic Shield but I want
the blue ring instead
hey blacklinks you are back
I don't need to be in here
well the problem is with my color scheme
I cannot see if a door has a keyhole in
it it's too the contrast is too high
it's very annoying
oh wait I can just do the thing I need
to go over there see what's inside level
five I think it was yeah I'm surprised
you remember
that's five right yeah it is
yeah I know my Zelda
oh don't you do it
okay
I'm not gonna take the risk why are so
many old men who just stare at you when
you walk into their house and don't say
anything why are there so many old women
running a casino
are the old woman supposed to be the
ones doing the money making games
yeah I think maybe uh maybe also the
guys do it I'm not sure
so far it's just been uh
old ladies
what
it's a secret to everybody is this the
four one no it's not the four one it's
the 36 one
is there yeah I remembered
it's another secret to everybody
88 88 I'm good so we lost 12 on what it
what it was normally then
we also gained six on the 30 group time
for a blue ring
if I can survive up until that point
there we go
yeah probably no
probably far far stupid differences in
time zones yeah
I always get confused by it
let's see what color I got I'm gonna be
it's Ah that's boring it's green I mean
I mean green is my favorite color but
yeah we randomized The Outfits so I
thought it was going to be something
like pink or magenta or something
special but no it's just a slightly
darker green than normal
[Music]
it is an ice cream yet at least it's not
like
radioactive green it could also be like
an
ugly shade of like a yellow or something
like lime green something like that
I mean lime is pretty good
I was more thinking like
you know those are those uh markers that
you used to highlight oh yeah like that
green
eyesore green actually it's more like
yellowish but it's yeah like I said you
could also be like puke yellow or
something I think in Dutch we call it I
I strain in yellow or something
oh because he can heal uh
I mean maybe I've never heard of it but
I'll I trust you on this
you should why you should trust me
because I'm older
really yeah that that means I'm right
about everything that reminds me of like
the the meme there's like uh respect
your elders no not that one there and I
saw like an image and it was like um
like a guy from 1999 talking to a guy
who was born in 2000 and he was like uh
watch what you say I've lived 10 uh
times the amount you have or something I
don't remember the exact way it goes but
pretty good
the varia Sudan metric Fusion AKA puke
design
another secret to everyone
I can buy the magic magic Shields see
all the secrets it's in this cave look
here
oh I've already been to that one I
haven't
the 88 one though
you probably already forgot where it was
anyway you are all at my Mercy
prepare to be slaughtered
no no it's not this one no it's actually
a pretty cruel fade
guy comes in picks up a stopwatch is
Frozen in your tracks and you're
helpless while you just beat you in the
face with a sword oh no
oh no level nine yeah you can't go in
I'm pretty sure uh you can go like wrong
one room and then he's like no you need
to find all the one all the pieces oh
yeah there it is
oh boy that's the last the only level I
was hoping not to find it's like
I like the the I like what getting this
done with the place like bright pink is
his secret lair
ah just my color
more Zelda linked to the Past series
what that sell the link to the past is
quite kind of hard to theorize about
because it I don't know it doesn't
really have that many things like secret
lore
except maybe the Civil War stuff
but there's no like buildings where you
can be like oh this is clearly meant to
be a Water Filtration plant or something
when it comes to theories usually it
it's more like pertaining to the
timeline placement and stuff like that
okay I haven't seen many
the greatest invention ever
oh
yeah I really should have mapped the
controls to the control stick and not
the d-pad
man I have an itch in my throat really
annoying
oh no no Linus
I don't want to mess with them
they go in this one
please tell me to the one I'm looking
for no it's not
it's good enough but I was hoping to
find the idea if I find the 88 one then
I can buy the blue ring too but
let's see oh level seven well well don't
keep finding everything don't I just
blend into the background nicely it's
pretty much the exact same green it is
the same green I think
I'm just a floating head
are you now yeah you're right it's like
the exact that's the exact same green
it's camouflage why is links happening
because he was just feeling fashionable
I am dying so much
I need the blue ring oh
let's see what's inside here
oh really that's you're about to die
finally and then you get saved and I
don't well you don't get your hearts
back though oh that's weird yeah I miss
remember only when you pick up a
Triforce that's when you get all your
hearts yeah and you're in the lionels
then right now
the Lino's then yeah instead of the
lines then it's Limestone oh I don't
have the Magic Shield I'm dead
Justice that's why he's green it's
camouflage yeah
there was no way to escape from that
situation except like keep running back
and forth from the top screen
until they
don't appear in that entrance of uh
entrance way
we need the candle so we have more
options to check
preferably the blue candle no preferably
the rest of the the red cat yeah but you
actually do you need to get the blue one
first before you can get the red one let
me check what's inside level two okay
I'll check level three first
oh you're close to level
I'm not close yeah all the way down is
level three oh yeah yeah oh yeah you're
right I haven't looked there I haven't
looked there yet I will go check out
level two and
if I can find it I I'm all I always get
confused where level two is exactly in
relationship to I know where it is
approximately but
oh it still hit me
faster
I just wanted almost somewhere around
here right
this one no
okay that's that's what I mean
you drop bombs don't you
know you just throw up a heart the only
time I don't need it oh sorry
oh there's also a cave up here
oh it's not up here come on give me
bombs
there we go that's what I needed just
what I needed
what is that from again it's Mario yeah
but when does this is that Mario Mario
Advance 2
I don't know I just remember I think it
is right I remember hearing it when he
gets like an extra alive or something
yeah well when he picks up uh a mushroom
just what I needed yeah it's such a
funny line
Charles Martin a man he's a National
Treasure
I saw a video of him today he's like on
on some tropical island he's like look
at where I am Paradise I'm like good for
you man take all the take all the time
you want
yeah he's a hero you've worked for it
you've worked three lifetimes for
everyone who has you did a lot of yahoos
and yippies to get to this point oh my
God every time uh This is Gonna probably
not well maybe some people know every
time I hear yippee I just have to think
about uh Xenoblade 3 now
oh because of uh uh what's her name the
chain attack uh yeah mine I always
forget her name Santa Santa
when you choose her right for the 10
attack yeah
oh it's such a Xenoblade thing to to do
to keep repeating the exact same lines
all across the game until they're burnt
into your memory
let's show him a thing or three
thanks
you're on Firelands
so you you put a Xenoblade thing in your
uh video Once didn't you
yeah Lance wants something a bit meatier
why are you gonna play Alden ring you
lazy prick uh
[Music]
yeah there was an update I wanted to
play it yeah I'm playing I'm honestly
I'm it's a it's a good game so I have
like uh yeah it's a really good game you
need to play that one
I do and but yeah I have like a whole uh
backlog of games that I still need to uh
pick up I'm also planning to pick up um
because Half-Life uh well probably two
at some point but I actually remember
that uh there it is finally
why would anyone pick the potion in this
situation by the way I'm just wondering
if everyone if anyone has ever picked a
potion I think that's been on everyone's
mind since forever
like why would it even give you the
option why why trick us like this
but uh
yeah I have like uh one game that I know
I at least watched you play I think when
I was uh like when I was like way
younger is a Bioshock I actually I
actually want to play the game yeah
that's a that's a fun game yeah and
actually it's in the tree at the dead
end oh screw you and your secrets fine
then
so close
I was so close oh he only took like
hello
October that's a that's a great name
they take random amounts of money from
you I just noticed
they do yeah you just gave me uh you
only took 15 rupees for me
oh that hurts so much I guess it's
randomized too
all right we need to get our hand on a
candle
find out we haven't found the armo spot
yet there's an item in the Overworld
underneath the enormous an armos yeah
there's two armos in the forest
that's not these ones anyway
[Music]
should I risk it Xenoblade is a huge
time commitment that does not really
three three is not that bad
it depends on how much I play I played
through three in like one week less than
a week
yeah it depends on how much you want to
do really it can be a total sink if
you're like a total time sync if you
want oh that's a good idea to be fair
Xenoblade 3 is by far the least grindy
uh of all this you know well I don't
know about X because I haven't played X
or I shouldn't say every but from from
the main line the the first three ones
it felt like free you didn't need all
those field skills and yeah I
mean it's not necessarily less grindy
it's just a lot more user like friendly
like the most you get out of side quests
is like new Fighters which is a very
good reward but you don't need them to
finish the the game
I never I never got that ninja guy in
the sword Marsh
or like in the run-up to uh to the sword
Marsh
I forgot I got them all
yeah of course you gotta catch them all
so you're you're a bigger more hardcore
Xenoblade fan on me
for fun though like
probably has the best uh side content of
the trilogy
I mean definitely like the side quests
in the first game were pretty terrible
I say this is a very big fan of the
first game by the way which has
a lot of side quests that I just go get
me wood yeah and there's like no like
screw you I don't want to get wood go
get wood or else you cannot progress in
this story I mean there was no story
stuff like blocked in the first game but
there was no reason to do any side
quests pretty much well maybe if there
were like one or two that were like
actually rewarding and Europe being
pretty favorable on that game right okay
yeah but I can uh I can get this key I'm
mostly uh a fan of it because I wanted
the shield actually but
I'm a fan of it mostly uh for that which
one is your favorite one two or three oh
no don't ask me this question dude yeah
because I don't know everyone keeps
telling me this like
like a lot of people have asked me this
question and I always say like I don't
know they're that's like the funny thing
is when it comes to Xenoblade is that
there are people who adore the first
game and hate the second one there are
people who love the second one and hate
the third one level nine this is where
you found it yeah
and I'm just sitting here like I don't
know I love all three of these games and
I don't know I love them all for
different reasons so
that'll make sense
they all have their own uh it's like how
I view many Zelda games they all have
something the other one doesn't
so it's very hard to choose a favorite
because it just changes with your mood
like when it comes to like the world I
would never put Cinema 3 above Xenoblade
1 for example
like the bionics and the mcconus
yeah because it was a new
concept too yeah but like the world in
Xenoblade 3 itself just wasn't that
interesting it didn't have anything like
that made it like oh wow this is a cool
concept or anything it's just you know I
mean it does its job as a jrpg it's just
a world yeah there's like it's not like
wow I'm walking on two giant robots yeah
or I'm swimming in the clouds or stuff
like that yeah
foreign
is it possible to have two entrances in
on one screen it was right no
no nope
wait there's loads of armos this is I
already found it
you found the idle crap and I die too
yeah I found it well uh it's uh on a
Death Mountain yeah the line was then so
uh I got there great and now I need just
beautiful find out where the arrow is
because without the arrow I don't have
any use for this yet
oh yeah the music and Xenoblade is
incredible
it's a crime that they didn't win
soundtrack for OST best OST I the game
awards really just hates jrpgs yeah I I
heard people uh like it's I heart God of
War fans talk about how the best OST
reward was totally undeserved and it
should have gone to single blade three
yeah because
God of War has great music but it's not
like wow this is amazing this is out of
this world
I've listened to it it's a good
soundtrack but it's oh for sure it's but
to be fair uh it's very even though
Elden ring won it is a very Western
focused award ceremony yeah like at the
Oscars you also don't see as many uh
foreign films especially back in the day
now it's getting better I think that
Alden like if this was held in Japan but
it was mostly like Asian people like
attending it
I think Elder ring probably still would
have won but I think uh God of War like
I'm pretty sure Xena Blake would have uh
crushed God of War in Japan
in Japan for sure yeah
very different but also Zelda isn't even
that popular in Japan yeah neither is
God of War though
I think I think PlayStation in general
is not doing too well in Japan compared
to uh yeah other parts of the world
Elder ring did well like across the
globe though I'm pretty sure Zelda 2 is
criminally underrated
I'm not gonna tell you your opinion is
wrong but your opinion is wrong
it was it had a very interesting combat
system and it like if it is the type of
game you enjoy then for sure but as a
sequel to this game
it was a bit of a maybe a bit of a
slight step in the wrong direction oh
screw you old guy oh I took all he took
everything and took my life savings have
you had those times where an enemy
sometimes just randomly doesn't take
knockback when you swing at it a lot of
times they do it seems to depend on
their walking in the direction they're
walking if you hit them from the side
they don't get knocked back yeah because
that just and some enemies just don't
get knocked back in general the blue uh
blue were guys they should pretty sure
they should they're supposed to have
knockback with
oh it's the bow yeah where we don't have
we can't use it yet we need the arrows
at least it's slow yeah okay slow guy
what you can buy arrows in the shop
right you used to be able to but I
haven't seen them yet
I think
oh I don't do I still have bombs yeah I
do
oh it's I think I bombed the wrong wall
it's weird how the Oh oh oh please these
guys can combo you to death and
seconds it's weird how the blue tactiles
are like the one enemy
where the blue variant is weaker than
the red one for some reason
yeah I found that oh I just had enough
for the for the ring another green green
dungeon
uh Zelda 2 is uh it's it's definitely
not a bad game in terms of game design
or something like that it well it does
have some some of that cryptic NES stuff
but so does this game
many games did did back in the day it's
definitely not a game for me that's uh
I've tried we gave it I think both of us
gave it a shot after we completed this
one and we were like nah
it's just too difficult for me I'm not a
hardcore gamer yeah neither am I
although I did beat Ninja Gaiden
on NES really yeah I did and I'm very
proud of it
as a kid but then again so did Aaron
Hansen from the game grumps and he sucks
at video games
like he is so bad he might be the most
terrible Ocarina of Time player I've
ever seen
I mean he is so bad at Ocarina of Time
I'm like that's not even a difficult
game
not to criticize Mr Hansen but come on
I mean the three uh
before ones were at least
had some semblance of difficulty
oh for sure it wasn't like Wind Waker
easy just yet yeah like if you're if
you're well but it's still not like
super hard yeah but honestly if for like
if you're compared like a game like Wind
Waker where
unless you're playing in a hero mode and
even in hero mode I think it's way too
easy
another oh jeez
I think this dungeon might be a little
uh
why did your league yeah
why did the enemies get uh respawn
already I only moved one room
where did
it's camo link again yeah
I already dared you oh
oh oh God ah do you remember when the
shot where the shop was
the shop which shop the blue ring shop
in level one
really yeah level one the three stump
please tell me I have enough
I had enough and then
I had to paid for door repair Choice
Wind Waker is definitely the easiest
selling game Twilight Princess is also
extremely easy
like you have to actually try to die in
that game
well in those yeah I mean I don't think
I died once in any of the 3D games other
than Majora and Ocarina
I definitely died in Ocarina quite a bit
as a kid yeah me too but that was also
just because I was stupid but I I think
even kids would have a hard time dying
in wind wakers and it's impatient
yeah probably
which is fine by the way I don't think
windwake was ever meant to be difficult
no it's such a fun game it doesn't
matter it's
an incredible incredible game yeah but I
don't think it would really fit anyway
if it was like Dark Souls difficulty
like Wind Waker really
nah and I'm dead
okay we're gonna fall for you guys this
time
I think it's funny how Twilight Princess
went from a it's okay he's all the game
to now it's like everybody thinks it's
underrated
it's definitely well not everybody but a
lot of people think it's underrated now
and it's become kind of like uh yeah
it was definitely too easy though I
think most people realize oh the the
dungeons
dungeons in this game are actually
pretty damn good
and the story is really awesome
I guess at the time it didn't make the
same kind of impact because Zelda was
kind of known for doing something crazy
something new that wasn't like
revolutionized gaming in some way
and it just didn't do that
it was just Ocarina of Time 2.0 but
bigger but Ocarina of Time but bigger
but sometimes sometimes that's all you
need not every sequel has to do
something new just look at the John Wick
series which you didn't watch which we
will watch together very soon because
you have to watch John Wick
but like every John Wick is the exact
same thing again it's just more action
more shooting
and it works it's fine it doesn't need
to do anything more than that some
things never get old
no
I mean look at this game it's uh how
many years old now it's older than you
are so and it's still hanging around
people are still playing it
yeah
even though it's like what 36 years old
right now uh people are in in the breath
of the wild hate mode because it's the
latest Zelda game and the hype has now
settled and people are like I wasn't
actually that good in the weapon
degradation was terrible and I actually
didn't care at all about the weapon
degradation my first time playing not at
all I I was just amazed by how awesome
everything was even the even the times
after that I don't think I was ever
bothered by the weapon degradation
because I was like oh well I'll find
something else anyway well that was the
point
it was like you're always gonna be
finding new weapons I think the only
mistake they made is the champion
weapons I think those should have had
some way to repair them or something I
never used them because I didn't want to
lose them yeah that's true
should maybe or or like the master sword
they run out of some sort of yeah energy
and you get to keep them they're just
fine or if they break they just go back
to the
to like Soros domain or Rito Village you
can pick them up back up again there
yeah which you kind of can
but it's like supposedly like a replica
or something I don't know I know they
look you have to give them diamonds or
something
yeah I know they look the same but like
a lot at least well no they they have
the same stats but they look different
yeah just use the champion weapons on
Ganon
yeah
um like the weapons was not but one of
the reasons I didn't like the game or
anything there were things that I didn't
like that much about breathable but they
had nothing to do with the the combat or
the weapons I think those were actually
oh it's really well not as perfect as
we've like as some people who made it
out to be in the beginning but it's it
was still it's still a Monumental game I
mean
I I'm I think I got like which isn't bad
at all for a Zelda game for like a
normal Zelda game I think I got like
60 or 70 hours of entertainment out with
which is perfectly fine for a Zelda game
for 3DS all the game I I definitely got
a little bit more than that but yeah for
me it was like best a 60 hour mark I
started to realize that a lot of the
stuff that I was doing was the same
stuff that I was doing before like I was
just collecting more stuff that I
probably was never going to use
like the how many hours are in a week
approximately like if you would play
every day for 10 hours
well seven more now let's say more
well 70 plus the amount more that you're
talking what is like the max amount of
uh sleep to play ratio because I did
play I did finish breath the wild in one
week uh probably about a week I think if
you sleep eight hours and your entire
waking hours is just playing breath of
wild then it's six well that was pretty
much it yeah well maybe 15 hours if you
have like to take like an hour to eat
stuff so
yeah 15 hours a day probably
but I did play a little bit more after
that of course and did some extra quests
you still played on streams too play
Downstream
I'm not gonna count all the hours I
spent playing breath of the wild
recording footage for my channel yeah it
doesn't count it's not the same
the amount of time you spend uh
observing uh what was his name what was
his name again
yeah the amount of time you spent
observing Larry yeah I'm not gonna count
that
what if they put an East Dragon Tears of
the kingdom and there's a vocabul named
I will be very happy if that's the case
rather than I can die happy if that that
ends up yeah true you're just gonna
you're gonna quit quit your career
because your life is gonna become a monk
yeah because your life is complete I'm
gonna travel to Tibet and become a monk
knowing that I have served my life's
purpose yeah so Nintendo acknowledged my
work
and it's never gonna happen though
I don't think there's a single content
creator that Nintendo has ever
acknowledged to be perfectly honest uh
there is one
isn't that like a room in A Link to the
Past named after guy
oh yeah yeah but that was like a contest
thing from a long time ago was that a
contest yeah sure
not there
I thought that was so uh humbling to see
when technoblade died and they put him
in Minecraft on the title screen oh yeah
it's like man that like here's a
developer that truly knows its audience
and knows the impact that these players
have on
not only the sales of big games but just
the community surrounding it and stuff I
remember seeing like the like a chart of
gaming companies
and there was like the uh
uh there is good in uh well there's evil
in good which is like Nintendo which is
good but has evil in it oh yeah there's
Chris hooligan yeah and then oh sorry
yeah there's like a
uh like a chart of uh how evil is the
company that the whose games you play
and it was like there's a good companies
with EVO in them which would be Nintendo
and then there's like evil companies
with good in them which would be like EA
or something
and then there was a like pure good
which was just Mojang
it's not like they're wrong
well every developer has its flaws but
Mojang I'm finding it hard to find
anything that like I mean they make
mistakes if they ever had anything like
hugely controversial happening to them I
don't think so not really
as far as I know I mean I've been I'm
like like even developers that are like
known for putting out like great quality
like Naughty Dog they still get at least
some uh they got some
yeah but stuff with The Last of Us Part
Two and how they reacted to the
criticism to the game yeah honestly if
you've been on top if like if you've
been on YouTube for any length of time
there's bound to be something
like that people are no there's nothing
I did not have a like
problem with the Last of Us Part 2 story
or anything but
I can understand why people were
disappointed in the game at least
without making it out to be like oh
they're just they're just hating on this
character because it's a masculine woman
or something I'm like well some people
just don't like the fact that their
favorite character got like
killed in the first few minutes or
something
honestly I think everyone's opinion is
valid whatever you want to like whatever
you're like this guy
oh we shouldn't have randomized the
monsters man
wow but it's like when you criticize
stuff sometimes they tend to lump you
together with people you don't want to
have anything to do with and like your
opinions don't
uh correspond with at all
yeah maybe
it's like the people that really hate uh
what's a what's a good show to to to
hate on
uh I don't know
something at least I've watched because
I haven't watched the new Velma show yet
because I'm not I've heard a lot I'm not
even gonna talk about it I'm not even
gonna try it because it's just gonna
make me angry because I love Scooby-Doo
and I grew up with it I'm like nope why
why would I subject myself to this
it's clearly not made for me
Game of Thrones season eight that's a
good one for anyone but that's like
universally hated right nobody defends
season eight
nobody's like yeah that made sense like
uh brand on the on the on the Iron
Throne yeah let's do it
at least not that I remember
but yeah most of the time though I'm I'm
just like did you let people just let
people have their opinions man Big Bang
Theory
that that's a that's a decent one
I love the Big Big Bang Theory until
they all started getting girlfriends and
wives and children and I was like well
now it's just normal life now it's not
like nerds anymore who are living in
their basement playing Halo all day
which was the funny part of it
like these socially awkward guys
but now it's just it's become just a
regular soap series
might as well just be called renamed to
friends at that point
lost
I really like lost
even the last uh three seasons
and I totally understand why the story
went the way it did
you've never seen lost right no I
haven't
that is that is a show that had such a
big impact on like Series in general
like
no matter what you think of lust it was
it's one of the reasons why we have like
these big more cinematic almost
movie-esque
uh like TV shows now
it kind of started it whoa that that was
a very weird transition
oh yeah the room of death I've been here
and I immediately wanted to leave
yeah that's true you could technically
hate on anything
but why would you
oh no I remember this oh no I might be I
might be screwed
such a waste of energy
yeah I'm pretty sure I'm screwed dude
you are the red bubbles they take your
sword and you have to touch a blue one
oh no that's like second question yeah I
forgot about stuff I forgot about the
the red bubbles
but I think I might be self-locked
yeah I'm pretty sure I'm screwed here
um they did because there's nowhere for
me to go in the dungeon rings of power
is is I thought it was fun but you know
I'm very easily entertained
I'm sure it's just me
I don't value True Entertainment
but I yeah I enjoyed it it's not as good
as a Peter Jackson Trilogy obviously
which uh Jesse only saw for the first
time fairly recently last year which one
Lord of the Rings oh yeah the Peter
Jackson trilogy
but there's a series based on Lord of
the Rings now called rings of power yeah
I've heard of it
which is
it you're not gonna recap like Peter
Jackson could not recapture the magic of
The Lord of the Rings trilogy so you're
a mixed people were mixed about it I
think yeah it's just a a mixed show
that's it
yeah ignoring is usually the better
choice
oh here's the arrow oh and the candle
hey Clifford thanks that means a lot
and welcome back by the way
dude how have you been
should be a bombable wall here yeah
uh I found I I have another blue ring I
have to just buy another one dude I
found the Gucci should I stack do I get
like twice uh the damage reduction
oh where a line knows then somewhere
okay I'm but I was just about to get the
Magic Shield too
at least you have the money for it I
have no money
uh still yet to watch Lord of the Rings
like I could set up and binge the whole
uh the whole Mandalorian in one go but I
just cannot bring myself to watch a Lord
of the Rings
uh I mean if you're having trouble with
it then
I don't know
I do remember me not really being into
the first movie as much as other people
were
and then I saw the second and the third
and I was like uh it was just magic
can Lionel stop spawning on this no they
cannot never
just keep we are dutchies yes
the tiniest Dutch people in the world
well not the tiniest but
we are not tall
totally stuck right now
not that it matters we're basically
dwarves in a nation of giants yes
I'm just gonna get myself killed
hopefully it'll bring my sword back
because this is really annoying
hello Mojo
foreign
we need a bed of Sword man I can't even
use my sword so it doesn't matter
yeah I'm pretty sure I might have to
restart the whole thing because there's
no way I'm gonna complete it without a
sword
I totally forgot about the the red
bubbles were even the thing
yep
that is Avant
that is headsaker
a fairy fountain will restore your sword
does it yeah says you sure says Rebecca
m
who may have just saved your life
we're gonna
oh oh it actually does I never knew that
well there we go we learned something
about this game thank you uh Rebecca m
M I don't think I've ever left a dungeon
with my sword gun so I have no idea I
was just on the impression that this
game was we should have excluded these
the the
but we wanted to do yeah we wanted to do
mix quests so it's our own fault but
yeah it makes twist is fine as long as
the red bubbles aren't in there oh well
that's oh no shut up you mean the
batteries on your NES are running low
right yeah because we're totally playing
this on NES yeah it's uh like NES Zelda
randomized Edition
I want to get the Magic Shield because I
have to deal with those Lino's and then
I'll get the candle and then we'll
probably have to go to the pump which
oh oh geez yeah we have shoes I think we
have to call it quits pretty much now
yeah like five minutes it's usually when
we start well then I will get the shield
and then I will just save the game to my
battery pack NES
I'll just absolutely keep it here
uh don't remind me that I have to save
the game
you have to save the game
no I mean when we leave in a few minutes
well it's not like I'm working for
Nintendo with Nintendo or in cab in any
sort of collaboration with Nintendo so I
can say whatever I want
it's not like Nintendo's ever gonna send
me an email like hey monster it's so
cool that you're promoting our game and
making so many people
hype for it you know we really
appreciate it but you're just gonna show
up at your doorstep no at best they're
gonna copyright strike me because I use
a Mario Kart egg track or something
it's it's still I I still can't
like why haven't they uploaded their own
soundtrack yet at this point
because they don't want to make money
but but they also don't want to make
like have other people make money like
there would be absolutely no more like
no need at all for like Nintendo music
channels at all if they just made their
music available on YouTube or Spotify or
something
like it's free advertisement they can
put like ads on them and stuff
yeah but no Nintendo doesn't know how to
internet yet this is not their strong
suit is this just a like a Japan thing
where they don't grasp the concept of
capitalism yet oh yeah the Nintendo
ninjas we have to switch subjects now
or else they're gonna take me down
walk into the waterfall yeah thanks it's
not like I didn't know that FBI open up
go down here
nope
I love Nintendo they're out of control
it's great
unless you're on the receiving end of it
I always I always feel so bad for those
people who made like fan projects I like
one actually they like spent like years
of their life on it and it just they get
a cease and assistant it's just gone I
mean to be fair they they know the risk
of doing it so starting a project like
this is dangerous
but I still feel bad for them because I
know how much work goes into that kind
of stuff yeah this guy is way too
difficult for this point in the game
well because that's why I said we let it
we need a better a better sword and I
think this was like the level five guy
or level six there's another two-headed
one
uh yeah there's two of them next of it
I actually have made a fan project
myself
this game I think really didn't I show
it to you before oh yeah yeah you did uh
for those who are wondering it was my
college project
I thought I was gonna do something with
game development when I I was in college
and I ended up switching
I ended up switching to uh web
development afterwards because of like
job opportunities and everything and
everything because you can actually make
money off of that yeah
um but yeah I I actually made a
like a completely original like well not
completely original it has all the items
of this game
but I made a completely new Overworld
and everything
yeah I remember that so uh we still have
the code I do uh I well I think I do
and I do have the exe still but uh
yeah if I put it out there it's probably
gonna get a
I'm probably going to get the knock on
my door from in the from Nintendo from
the ninjas yeah but it was like I
programmed it myself uh all the items
like they all work exactly the way they
do in this game it's not like I took the
code of this game I just used uh use a
game maker uh game maker engine to make
to remake this game basically
it's pretty cool
that's pretty neat
it has no title and I never finished it
though but all the items were functional
I just never bothered to design any of
the dungeons candle
and I don't have money
all right yeah I'm gonna just uh should
probably uh yeah we're we're gonna head
off guys Jesse's got a train a train to
catch I have to go
or a Subway actually it's a subway
subway train Subway sandwich
Jesse's gonna get Nintendo you're gonna
come home and there's gonna be a
like something in your room like a knife
sticking in your wall with a letter from
Nintendo we're watching you we're
watching you how do you save in this
game again or just uh an exit of our
conversation right now yeah exactly uh
how do we save this game I have I don't
remember should I just die and then yeah
just use a a safe State oh yeah but you
can do that after we turn off the stream
because uh there's a the street the uh
what is it called like the cropping is
all based on how oh that's probably
Carol calling me about your train
but yeah thanks all for uh joining we're
gonna head off and we'll see you next
time yeah see you next time guys bye-bye
[Music]